cartoon se vide dans un mouvement de
panique le personnel diplomatique est
évacué dans des avions militaires des
opérations délicates menées par les
forces spéciales dans un pays en proie
aux violences
pour avoir évacué 58 citoyens canadiens
sans conduit c'est pas mal pour un
premier vol si la Canon
occupé
la moitié de l'avion alors on a une
dette envers l'Allemagne
un avion C17 canadien serait maintenant
posté dans la région pour mener des
opérations à son tour la nuit dernière
ce sont les meringues américains qui ont
évacués 6 diplomates canadiens on
opération rapide
immédiate il reste un gros problème et
ce sont des 1500 Canadiens qui restent à
cartoon dans une situation franchement
effroyable
si la France est parvenue à sortir
rapidement plus de 1000 ressortissants
hors du Soudan les employés de l'ONU ont
dû prendre la route pour atteindre Port
Soudan sur les rives de la Mer Rouge en
attendant un vol ou un navire
fuir la capitale n'est pas un luxe que
peuvent se permettre tous les Soudanais
avec l'augmentation du prix de l'essence
Karam réalise que le prix du trajet en
bus vers l'Egypte et passer de 80 à plus
de 300 dollars ce premier infirmé
un convoi à temps pour traverser la
frontière égyptienne ceux qui ont pu se
payer le bus prennent le thé à la
cafétéria Intissar se repose un peu
maintenant quel est en sécurité
le plus difficile dit-elle c'est de
quitter son pays en pensant au son des
explosions et des coups de feu j'ai
choisi de partir avec mes enfants
à l'origine des violences deux généraux
qui rivalisent pour le pouvoir eux qui
ont orchestré le coup d'État en 2021
Abdel Fatah Al bourrane est devenu chef
d'État Mohamed Hamdan daglou qui dirige
une puissante force par un militaire à
retourner ses armes contre son ancien
allié ce n'est pas une guerre soudure
c'est une guerre entre deux armées peu à
peu ils vont essayer de manipuler la
population sur les bases ethniques au
tribal
à cours d'eau potable et d'électricité
le tiers des 46 millions du soudanais
ont besoin d'aide humanitaire des
centaines de civils ont perdu la vie
depuis le 15 avril devant
une nouvelle tentative de Cécile feu de
72 heures promues par les États-Unis est
entré en vigueur ce soir mais les
précédents efforts pour une paix
temporaire ont tous échoué à présent ici
Jean-Philippe Radio-Canada Montréal
[Musique]